welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Whitney van laningham and it's time to
grab your brellies and Don your Wellies
because this week's Rick and Morty is
drenched in pissed and therapy but
mostly pissed today I'm taking you frame
by frame through season 6 episode 8 of
Rick and Morty to break down all the
details you might have missed and
analyzed piss just a heads up I'm gonna
be bleeping a lot during this video
because I don't want to anger Papa
YouTube with my potty mouth let's kick
things off with the episode title
analyze piss is a play on Analyze This a
movie from 1999 starring Robert De Niro
is an anxious mafioso who seeks therapy
from Billy Crystal although Rick doesn't
interrupt Dr Wong during her wedding
festivities to tell her that he can't
get a boner this episode does explore a
troubled man opening himself up to
therapy it's always a treat to have
Susan Sarandon on the show and somehow
she's finally gotten through to Rick the
episode opens in Atlantis where Rick and
Morty are battling Mr Nimbus the series
name or parody from season 5's more
dinner Rick Andre Morty is set up an
elaborate bunker embedded in a coral
reef where he's shooting tiny little
clams at their adversaries octopus goons
when Rick launches Mr Nimbus into the
side of a boat causing an oil spill you
can see the vessel's name that ever G's
the Evergreen Marine Corporation is a
shipping container Corporation the
ship's names all begin with the word
ever just like this one remember back in
2021 when that container ship got stuck
in the Suez Canal that ship was the ever
given after Mr Nimbus exits in a
spectacular display of thrusting and
nipple moisturizing Rick and Morty start
to pack up to head home but are
interrupted by a dork named cookie
Magneto who wants to fight Rick if you
thought we were done fighting a bunch of
weird annoying villains after that story
Lord episode last week you'll have
another thing coming Buffalo cookie
Magneto has the power to control the
ingredients of what we all agree are
cookies which as Morty points out can
become a real problem in the same way
that Magneto can technically control the
iron in your bloodstream cookie Magneto
can make your blood sugar Bend to his
will Rick ices this guy before their
battle can begin because he doesn't want
to fight a bunch of goofball villains
like he's the tick The Tick was
originally a comic character drawn in
1986 by cartoonist and edlined as a
parody of popular superheroes but gained
mainstream success in his own titular
1984 animated series the tix Rogues
Gallery was full of ridiculous baddies
like chair face Chippendale breadmaster
and the chainsaw vigilante and cookie
Magneto would fit right into their crew
Morty suggests that his grandpa do some
soul-searching to figure out why all of
these wackos keep starting beef with him
although Rick initially refuses to give
it any thought he reconsiders after Mr
Calypso shows up to fight too this
little dude is a parody of Mr mixius
fitlick one of Superman's silliest foes
originally introduced in Action Comics
number 80 Mr Mixie is a fifth
dimensional imp that can the end of the
world to his cartoon logic despite the
fact that he still refuses to see it as
going to therapy Rick busts into Dr
Wong's office looking for answers as to
why these freaky little [ __ ] won't
leave him alone when she asks him to
define the situation Rick says this I'm
a walking Target for a never-ending sea
of angry nerds that think getting in a
fight with me is some kind of I don't
know platform this clearly isn't just
one character's bewilderment about his
enemies it's metacom commentary on the
Rick and Morty fandom itself which let's
be real can get pretty toxic at times
not only is Rick trapped in an oroboros
of his own refusal to ignore outside
interference the writers of this series
itself are stuck in an unending sea of
fan commentary Network notes and
internal self-criticism Rick also makes
a comment about how calling him out for
being an ugly drunk is a poor angle of
criticism and that it's like shooting
Batman in his bulletproof logo Rick
knows that he's an ugly drunk that's his
brand and the show is responding to
critique that treats obvious surface
level observations as dunks this
interaction also plays to one of the
episode's greater themes the popularity
and renowned Talent while desirable goes
hand in hand with your haters looking to
knock you off your pedestal and into the
yellow stink drink for once Rick decides
to take Dr Wong's advice to see if
anything in his life changes for the
better if he ignores the villains
projecting their insecurities and egos
onto him and focuses on doing his own
thing and the Smith family is actually
really supportive Jerry even commends
him for accepting the concept therapy
without first needing to turn himself
into a pickle or a house fly call back
to season three's pickle Rick Rick later
turns Mr goldenfold into a fly in Dr
Wong's office so Jerry's Theory might
not be wrong Jerry for I think that was
a regular fly in her office that day
Rick has animorph Tech ready to go
despite Rick's new more relaxed attitude
towards pop-up Nemesis his master shows
up to give the Smith's dining room
window a golden shower voiced by Will
Forte this Green Goblin parody has the
perfect name for a front man in an
anti-fascist black metal band his real
name is Eugene Michael piss and his goal
is to be number one at number one this
new guy makes Jerry especially angry not
only because pissmaster is displaying
some high-key R Kelly Behavior towards
Summer but also because he's ruining the
lavender bushes so beloved by his bees
if you don't remember here you became a
beekeeper in the episode tag of season
4's primordius summer I wanna oh really
I love the low effort fist fight that
these two dads get into we're so used to
seeing Rick's high-tech fast-paced
fights that this feels like pulling
teeth in comparison while Summer Films
their all we catch a glimpse of their
neighbor Gene just before Jerry steals
one of his lawn flamingos and beats the
piss out of pissmaster also that kid in
the background has on a 69 shirt nice
yeah me
Jerry forces piss Master to apologize
and he jets away sobbing Rick uses his
scanner to instantly heal Jerry's
internal and external wounds allowing
him to make out with Beth more
comfortably it's really interesting to
compare Jerry in this episode to Jerry
the last time we saw him in Beth in
therapy with Dr Wong in the season 4
finale star Mort Rick turn of the Jeri
Tammy and her Galactic Federation
Troopers explode through Dr Wong's
office and attack bat back then this was
Jerry's response hey I only said hey
it's not like I can do more than that
he's come a long way from the cowering
sniveling version of himself from
previous seasons and we love to see it
over a bowl of strawberry smiggles the
family discusses Jerry's new viral Fame
this disturbingly delicious cereal was
first seen in a commercial back in
season one's brixty minutes and the
Smith also munched down on them in
season two's Big Trouble in Little
Sanchez and the wedding sponsors the
hashtag Flamingo dad has gone viral and
BuzzFeed even made an odd-numbered list
of other people's observations about
Jerry this is obviously a out calling
out buzzfeed's content style which
compiles Twitter reactions into odd
numbered lists to maximize attention
grabbing headlines summer also says that
he's getting a lot of hand clap emojis
on white Twitter's impersonation of
black Twitter critiquing the way that
social media perpetuates a cycle of
mining consuming and ultimately erasing
Black Culture next Beth calls out sites
that take a consistently aggressive
contrarian view to viral Fame excitedly
telling Jerry that Jezebel's offering a
cash reward for evidence that you're a
bad person that is their highest honor
back in 2014 Jezebel infamously offered
a ten thousand dollar reward for
unphotoshopped images from Lena Dunham's
Vogue cover shoot calling out Vogue and
photographer Annie Leibowitz in the
process the Smith musings are
interrupted when blagner the Eternal
voiced by Dietrich Vader and another
member of the galactic warp ship voiced
by John early asked Jerry to join them
in protecting the Galaxy fun fact
Dietrich Vader best known for voicing
Batman in multiple animated series
including most recently Harley Quinn
leaded back in September 2021 that his
new career goal was to guest star on
Rick and Morty and it looks like his
prayers have finally been answered this
Galactic orb ship is a play on Green
Lantern's Owen Guardians of the universe
only instead of gifting their Heroes
Lantern rings Pinky and the Brain over
here bestow upon Jerry a silver jizz
oozing orb wow it's sticky it alerts him
to Intergalactic injustices Jerry asks
so so what do I do rub the orb when I
see crime or or eat the orb like spinach
a nod to both DC's Shazam adjacent
Captain Thunder who rubbed his belt
buckle and yelled Thunder to activate
his powers and Popeye the sailor man who
eats spinach to grow strong despite
Rick's foreshadowing that if he gives
Jerry raw power he'll just end up
miserable like him the Smith family
manages to bully him into crafting
Jerry's power armor inspired by comic
heroes like Iron Man and Blue Beetle
this Mark has nuclear disruptor blasters
with Planet destroying capabilities
which is a completely overpowered
invention Rick basically turned the
strength of the entire death star into a
bracelet if Rick pitched this product to
guest shark Darth Vader on Shark Tank
Anakin would partner with Lori Grenier
get a Utility Patent and put these
gauntlets on interdimensional QVC Jared
first mission to take out a legion of
Hitler's gathering on zeppler Prime this
Legion of Doom parody Sports Hitler's
hairstyle and mustache as their logo
their roster is made up of Hitler
gorilla a parody of Gorilla Grodd Hitler
Riddler a parody of the Riddler mantis
Hitler six side Hitler who might be
Trigon Hitler old Hitler Julius Caesar
Hitler and Brandon ajar Hitler a parody
on the brain in a vapro Paula Marvel's
brain drain crane from the Ninja Turtles
and Hector con Carney from Evil con
carne honestly I was actually expecting
to see the Hitlers from the fascist
shrimp and stuffed animal Dimensions
from season 4's edge of to Morty Rick
die Rick Pete but I guess they weren't
invited to Hitler Khan when Jerry
arrives on the scene kick an ass we see
this scene from the opening credits for
a second time featured in the actual
show in full meta Jack rack previously
on Paul's Rick and Morty through the
opening credits of the series which I
thought was the only explanation of
these sequences we get for this season
but surprise this isn't one of previous
Leon's toxic nightmares it's an actual
scene from Analyze piss have we seen the
future now will Morty melt Jerry uses
his nuclear disruptor blasters to go
full Alderaan on zeplar Prime becoming
an Intergalactic hero the news
celebrates him as Jerry Smith Station
finally a cool death when Flamingo fam
69 goes live they get an influx of over
75 trillion viewers turning in including
this girl sending heart emojis some are
proud of her dad this butt overlooking a
sunrise that says sleigh Flamingo dad
squanchy who says yeah right loser taken
out a blob alien who calls Jerry a
flamingo dilf a queen bee who comments
that she's heard he's into bees you
don't have to be a Super Genius to
realize that you're not gonna get
another set of skin or a new head of
hair anytime soon you might as well take
care of what you got which means you
should really get familiar with geology
geology is a 14-time award-winning
personalized skincare company recognized
in men's health Esquire and ask men
grooming Awards with over 6 000 5 Star
reviews and they've recently expanded to
offer products for pretty much whatever
you need if you need Hair Care use
geology's co-wash especially formulated
cream cleanser that removes buildup and
cleanses the hair without the big lather
or or harsh ingredients of typical
shampoo and for the rest of your shower
routine you can use their body washes
which are free of harsh ingredients
smell great and are reliable and for
after the shower protect your skin from
environmental stressors with vitamin c
and e feralic serum to keep your skin
looking young and healthy and then a bit
of dermatologist tested aluminum free
deodorant that political it honestly
smells great right now for a limited
time geology is hooking our audience up
with an absolutely Bonkers offer if you
use the code new rockstars they'll give
you an additional 70 off of their
award-winning skincare trial set this
discount stacks on top of their current
sale prices and there's also an
additional bonus offer on one of their
brand new skin hair and body products of
your choice when you add it to your
trial with the holidays right around the
corner geology has you covered check out
their awesome gift sets featuring all of
your favorite geology products to get
started just click the link in the
description take a 30 second diagnostic
quiz and their team of dermatologists
will design a personalized routine just
for you that ships directly to your door
Rick of course isn't taking Jerry's
Newfound Fame very well he busts into Dr
Wong's office interrupting her session
with Mr goldenfold we learned in pickle
Rick is seeing her for coprophagia by
temporarily turning golden fold into a
fly you freeze this poop eater from his
shame why is entire evolutionary Niche
depends on waste so I'm guessing that he
finally found peace with his very gross
diet somehow Rick shows Dr Wong the
problem Jerry is over rescuing breakfast
world's egg people from an evil piece of
toast and he's just sitting around on
his keister Jerry uses science powers to
rid the world of evil and he's the hero
Rick does it and he's the enemy
doesn't seem fair I love the detail in
this tiny glimpse of breakfast World by
the way they've got an egg Sun a
flapjack stack building a milk carton
building a bacon building a waffle
building with fork Windows honeycomb
street lights and a toaster trailer 10
bucks says that this is the planet where
butter Morty lives I do want to note
though that Jerry seems prone to
excessive force here seen when he drags
the toast back in for another round of
humiliation just as he did with the
drink more water yellow Goblin during
the episode we see that Jerry can start
fights but he doesn't know when to
appropriately end them as nice as it is
to see Jerry not be a total leave it's
pretty clear that Jerry can't
responsibly wield power and is more
motivated by praise and Status than
ending conflicts out of the goodness of
his own heart Dr Wong points out that
Rick is basically complaining that
Hitlers are dead and encourages him to
focus on the changes he's making by
actually treating his immense power with
care once again he realizes that she's
right and decides to further Embrace his
freedom from fighting with Super Idiots
at the launch of Mitsubishi's face
Lancer an extremely subtle not at all
heavy-handed commercial Diane Mr string
bean invoiced by Tom Kenny rumbles up
just like Sonic challenging Rick to a
duel of fisticuffs when Rick refuses to
engage another soup named Dr buckles
shows up to battle in his place this
dude is some kind of bizarre Iron Man 2
Whiplash parody down to the accent but
Rick's victory of disengagement only
lasts a few drinks and he decides to pay
a visit to the one person in the Galaxy
as miserable as he is piss Master armed
with molson's Canadian beer for that
ultimate pure tinkle taste Rick heads
over to pissmaster's house in a scene
that invokes similar imagery to
Rorschach visiting Malik's dingy home
and Watchmen unfortunately Rick finds
piss Master dead by his own hand and
although he tries to heal his wounds
it's like Rick said back in season 1's
Anatomy Park well I can't cure death as
he's about to leave Rick hears
pissmaster's daughter at the door
blaming herself for her father's
depression realizing that pissmaster was
a father trying his best just like him
Rick decides to Don the helmet and give
his daughter some brief closure all
around pissmasters home or pieces of
evidence of a mediocre life sure there's
photos of his graduation in his first
car but the whole place is covered in
Piss dude the saddest items to me were
his collection of third place medals
offering a look into his psyche no
matter how hard he tried to go for the
gold and showers he always fell short
bathing in number One never made him
number one when Rick finds pissmaster's
unalive goodbye note he becomes
determined to give his life meaning
after building a better suit in a
sequence inspired by Tony Stark creating
his suit in the first Iron Man who's
able to use his technological genius to
create a newer better piss Master as
Rick begins to use the power of piss
selflessly for good Across the Universe
a parody of get ready for this by two
unlimited y'all ready for piss starts to
play Rick saves a woman from being
mugged with heat-seeking pistols oh okay
builds a ladder of pee to rescue a cat
from a tree and creates a frozen urine
skating rink outside the Children's
Hospital fun fact not only is rescuing a
cat from a tree superhero shorthand
started by Superman but saved the cat as
a writing term coined by Blake Snyder to
describe the moment in a story when the
protagonist demonstrates that they're
worth rooting for this device is used
literally here to hammer home this is
pissmaster save the cat moment redeeming
his legacy in an additional sense for us
Rick and Morty viewers this
Rehabilitation of pissmaster's image is
a save the cat moment in the series for
Rhett the stories had a long history of
criticism that Rick is simply an
irredeemable [ __ ] incapable long-term
change but this episode shows us that
this might not be true like Tony Stark
Rick Grace is the cover of Publications
like Newsweek and the times slaying
Godzilla with a pisticle next we see
another one of buzzfeed's tweet Roundup
so the white Twitter impersonating black
Twitter callback featuring a tweet from
foxy moonperson as Rick pp's on a
volcano to cool corrupting magma he gets
a call from Dr Wong checking in on him
he explains that he put on the suit of
his enemy and loves it and breaks down
his plan he's gonna make a giant bomb
planted in a city and have the suit
autopilot the bomb into space creating
the illusion that pissmasters sacrificed
himself and died a hero's death I can
tell you right now that if I called my
therapist and said any of those things
to her she would not be this chill about
it and would probably report me to the
authorities Dr Juan tells him to go for
it though so he heads over to Orphan
island with a giant explosive device
orphan island is exactly what it sounds
like an entire Island run by parentless
children straight out of industrial era
England their News network is called
orfn the kid leading the bomb squad is
trying to cut wires with safety scissors
I can't stress enough I'm eight years
old I have no idea what I'm doing in the
background there are several Billboards
that read Easter egg you're home for
love which I'm assuming operates like
eBay water the new milk Big John injury
attorney Ali boxes cardboard that won't
quit and twisted Cola get it like Oliver
twists at the corner of urchin row and
Wayward yard there's a general store
called rags and riches and next to it a
toasted nut cart also on that street you
can see a sign with a Newsboy hat next
to hawker's Hair Salon a hawker is a
merchandise Fender that sells
inexpensive goods handicrafts and food
items on an easily movable cart there's
also a pizza soup restaurant with the
tagline you'll want some more also from
Oliver twists orphan and Co or in
Littles a parody of big and tall and
Wayward yard clothing in this alley
we've got pieces of what looks like a
got coal sign an 800 number Gas Lamp
limited and an orphan Waiting For Soup
poster although Jerry doesn't realize
that his father-in-law is the one in the
pissmaster suit he's undeniably a little
peeved when the orb Council decides to
offer one to this guy ordered to hand
off the orb and maintain his place on
the council Jerry intercepts Rick's plan
giving the appearance that he wanted to
stop pissmaster from saving the orphans
when the two were spotted struggling
with the bomb in the sky one of the
orphans says life comes at you fast
which could be a reference to that quote
from those old Nationwide commercials I
suspect those commercials stole the line
from Ferris Bueller and rearrange the
words just a little but that's just me
Rick flushes himself from the piss
Master suit constructing it to autopilot
the payload taking the bomb far away
from the orphans the Trope of a hero
towing a bomb out of the city as a
sacrifice to save the world is super
common just look at Iron Man in the
first Avengers or Batman in The Dark
Knight Rises with those nukes the news
touts pissmaster a hero for laying down
his life and his piss for those orphans
and his daughter believes her dad died a
legend that's my [ __ ] dad to protect
himself and Jerry from the blast Rick
grabs the orb and hooks it up to a
device that casts power in front of them
like a shield to block the explosion
back with the family Rick initially
decides to spare his loved ones the
truth of pissmaster's Fate allowing them
to believe that their first interaction
with this master was Rick using a robot
or psionic James Cameron Avatar attack
to boost Jerry's self-esteem and the
Smiths would have bought it if Rick's
guilt hadn't forced him to confess the
truth to Morty when he comes clean Morty
immediately takes the unalive goodbye
note and shows it to the rest of his
family shattering the illusion that Rick
was getting healthier and that he truly
cared about Jerry and this is another
moment where we really see Morty's
growth in the past he would have taken
his Grandpa's lie to the Grave or at
least to the Mind Blower's fault now he
realizes that keeping Rick's [ __ ] up
Secrets isn't healthy and although it's
easy for the audience to see that Rick
really was trying to be selfless in his
own messed up way the Smiths are pissed
that they were elaborately deceived once
again lastly let's talk about that
post-credits tag the council is trying
to select new replacement members after
the downfall of flamingo dad and
pissmaster one of their potential
options is carjack Jack Miller a play on
classic comic book characters having
their secret identity as a pun on their
heroic aliases carjack looks like he may
have been inspired by Luke Cage or
absorbing man but ultimately he and
excessively casted scarjo are vetoed by
the group in favor of Mr Nimbus God damn
that man and his sorcelling pelvis
follow me on Instagram and Twitter
whitneypuppy follow me rockstars
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love and
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
thank you